- Hey, everybody!
Welcome to the first official episode
of the Wednesday Checkup.
I have my puppy, Bear, oh--
Is he still in the shot
when he's like this?
I have to tell you a crazy story
of something that happened to us
just a few days ago.
At the end of this video
I'm gonna be giving
you tips on how to protect yourself
in case a dog attacks you and how
to break up a dog fight if your dog gets
into a fight with another.
All right, let me get to the story.
Bear will come back a little bit later
and say bye to you guys.
A few days ago, I was filming
for the YouTube channel, surprise!
I'm not gonna tell you the video.
It's gonna be out later this month.
And I decided to take Bear downstairs
to the dog park.
Bear's there twice a day at least
so he knows all the other dogs.
He plays really well, especially
with the little Chihuahuas and Frenchies.
There's even one that looks
like a Wookie.
(wookie noise)
He loves it, he's in heaven,
they're all in heaven,
all the owners know Bear.
I get to the dog park,
I see a young lady come in
with a Golden Retriever.
First little suspicious sign is
her Golden Retriever pulled her in
to the dog park.
I was like "All right she
doesn't have great control
"of her dog."
and I watch these things.
I wanna know right away if there's
a problem dog coming in,
so I have to hold Bear,
make sure that he doesn't get hurt.
It still looked friendly,
tail was wagging and
it's a Golden Retriever
at the end of the day, you know.
And right away she tells me that
her dog doesn't really like big dogs
and is kinda afraid of them.
Bear said hi to that dog,
and it gave him like a little pause
and Bear just continued
along his merry way
playing with the other dogs.
So about five minutes go by,
all of a sudden I see that Bear
is standing right next to the Golden
side by side.
But they're showing all
the signs of aggression.
Frozen, mouths closed,
slobbering, tails up,
very rigid pose.
The other dog owner comes over
and sort of shoves her dog away from Bear.
And that triggers the Golden.
Snarling, and the Golden
just dives at Bear.
I initially was like
"Okay, a dog fight, I've seen these happen
"I know how to break this up, no worries."
As soon as I run up to
control the situation,
she grabs her dog's collar.
It was a big Golden Retriever
it was probably like 95 pounds.
She ends up falling with
the Golden Retriever
'cause there's a little mound in the park,
and she falls onto the
concrete holding the Golden.
The lady starts screaming.
Her Golden is locked on her forearm.
Her own Golden Retriever.
She's screaming "It's me, it's me!"
crying for help.
Two people from the street
jump the fence of the dog park,
start punching her dog in the face
to get it to let go 'cause it's,
I mean this is a big dog and
it's completely like smashing her forearm.
Finally it lets go, but
as soon as it lets go
it gets angry and jumps on her again.
Luckily all the people that were there
they were able to control
it with the collar,
pulling on it's legs, it's neck.
Pulled up her sweater
and showed me her wounds,
and she had deep puncture wounds
at least three deep puncture
wounds what it seemed like.
And some smaller cuts as well,
and bleeding from the nose and head.
And she's like "Well, I don't need
"to go to the hospital for this."
and I'm like "You really
need to see a doctor."
"You don't know if you have an infection.
"You don't know if you're
gonna continue bleeding.
"You need probably
stitches and antibiotics."
My adrenaline at that point
was just through the roof,
I've seen dogs get into fights many times,
it just happens.
You know, dogs are animals,
you have to correct them sometimes.
And I've even seen dogs
accidentally bite humans
when humans would put their hands
in the middle of a dog fight.
But I've never seen a
dog attack another dog,
who first of all wasn't being violent,
and then when separated, go after a human,
but not just any human, it's own human.
If that dog went for her neck,
and bit through her jugular vein,
or carotid artery,
she could have bled out and died.
Here's what to do if your
dog gets into a dog fight.
First, please, whatever you do,
don't stick your hands,
fingers, arms, legs,
in between two dogs that are fighting.
You're just asking to get bitten.
If you have two dogs that know each other
and they're sort of fighting at home,
a very simple thing to is
throw a blanket over them.
That would usually make them disperse.
If you're in a situation
where you wanna say no
and be firm and yell at a dog,
I wouldn't really recommend that.
Loud voices can actually get the dogs
even angrier and make them
wanna go at each other more.
Think about like a boxer
inside a boxing ring,
they don't hear people chanting,
they're just in the zone.
But on the off chance
if you have something
like an air horn that makes
a really loud high pitched noise
it can be loud enough
to disperse the fight.
Now the most effective way
to separate two dogs that are fighting
requires two people.
One on either side, behind the dogs.
You wanna pick up the hind legs,
and do something known as
a wheelbarrow technique.
As soon as you lift up the hind legs,
generally the dogs will wanna let go
because they don't know what's going on.
But as soon as you lift up the dogs
try and move in a circular fashion.
As you move in a circular fashion,
it'll give the dogs something to do,
but be careful because the dog will try
and kick it's legs out.
You really need to get a solid grip,
and you don't wanna get bitten.
Now what if the dog attacks you?
First of all, do not run whatever you do.
Dogs are very fast, and they
have a natural prey drive
that makes them wanna chase.
Stand up tall, stand sideways,
and not make eye contact.
So it's not confrontational.
You do still wanna keep an eye on the dog
without making eye contact.
Next in a firm voice, you
wanna tell the dog "No."
you just have to say it very passionately,
confident that you're willing
to stand your own ground.
At the same time, you wanna make fists.
And it's not because I want you
to get ready to fight the dog,
but it's because the
first things to get bitten
and bitten off are fingers.
If you keep them in fists,
you're less likely to lose a finger.
If the dog doesn't care that you
tried to stand non-confrontationally,
not make eye contact,
and gave it a command,
and it still attacks you,
at this point you have to
do what you have to do.
Punch the dog in the nose,
hit it in its throat,
those are its two most sensitive areas.
If you can kick it in the ribcage
that's another thing you can do.
And if you're completely losing the fight,
make sure to roll up
and protect your sensitive areas.
Your throat, and face.
If you're able to wrestle with the dog
and get on top of it and pin it,
know that the only way a
dog can really hurt you
is with it's mouth.
By getting on top of the
dog and pinning it down,
you can really neutralize the threat
of the dog biting you.
While you're fighting off this dog
you're also yelling for help
in the hopes that other people hear you
and come to your aid.
If the dog runs away
or you're able to get away,
call for help right away,
and you need to go see a doctor.
You need to make sure your
vaccinations are up to date.
If it was a rabid dog you may need
a series of injections.
You'll probably need antibiotics.
You may need sutures to stop the bleeding.
Get help as soon as possible.
The last thing you wanna do
is faint because of blood loss,
and not have anybody help you.
Once your health is taken care of
make sure you report the dog
bite to the proper authorities.
The last thing you want is for that dog
to bite another person or animal.
I'm not an animal behavior specialist,
I do have a lot of
experience in raising dogs
and understanding when
they're about to get angry
or do something wrong.
But even here I was shook.
I needed to go and look
up some information
about what to do to refresh my memory,
so I decided to make
this video for you guys.
Whether or not you own a dog,
I think this is useful information.
If you have any questions
about this story,
if you have any comments about this story,
jump in the comments section down below.
If you want more videos
with my little Bear pup,
please let me know
because I'm always down to film with Bear,
and he loves being on camera.
And most importantly,
as always, stay happy, and healthy.
(serene music)